jamais lien et un truc bizarre dans
l'ambiance la fois sur 10 à voir
si j'ai trouvé j'ai compris j'ai compris
pourquoi ça a changé l'ambiance le
comedy club lycée gentrifié
ouais on a nos réglages entre filles
mais
qu'est-ce qui en nageant on l'a fait on
a changé la façade ils ont trifouillé le
le bas c'est vrai on a gentrifié le sol
non c'est moi j'aime bien le nouveau
style non c'est pas ça que j'en retiens
gentrifié c'est à dire changer deux
populations c'est dans le public ya des
bobos maintenant tu sais le sait le
grand remplacement mais à l'envers
non moi j'adore je t'arrête tout de
suite moi je les adore oui bon je te
j'adore cette clientèle excusez moi le
but d'angers 1 d'abord ils réservent eux
et vous voyais il a 7 du bois sont chers
qu'on a payé pas cher nous
j'adore cette population mais l'ambiance
l'ambiance c'est pas la même avant au
tout début gmail comme on avait des
règles du pied car tu vas nous real
haschich et en plein air tout ce que
vous avez des mecs qui sortait de prison
qui venaient fêter ça i see it your way
ont fait la blague fils de [ __ ] je pas
entendu
et sûrs faisait la blague parce que tu
voulais pas finir dans un coffre là les
mobs aujourd'hui vide en trottinette
eelv ont kidnappé qui
mais tu trouves ils sont commandés keira
et le tir car il est là
[Applaudissements]
tu vois une tutoie yeux
et réserve pas
il touche le visage il vibre mais malgré
tout ça fait un super mélange désolé moi
j'aime quand tout quand quand ça se
mélange tu vois les bobos les babas les
pluies du début
tout le monde ensemble dans la joie et
la bonne humeur nom
du saint ponais que ça qu'on aime